شكرا للعيال اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام
نستكمل واياكم هذه التغطيه المستمره على
مدار الساعه من العربيه والخاصه باحداث
السودان نبدا من الخبر العاجل راويه الذي
وردنا قبل قليل عن فرقه الهجان التابعه
للجيش السوداني التي تعلن السيطره على
مواقع الدعم السريع في الابيض
اذن نتابع مثل ما ذكرت هذه التغطيه فعل
وقع اطلاق النار دخلت الهدنه ولكن قبل ذلك
نتابع هذه الصور وهذه الفيديو لفرقه
الهجان التابعه للجيش السوداني
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والصلاه والسلام
على
افضل الصلاه واتم التسليم
في يوم القوات المسلحه في يوم كبير من
ايام الهجانه ليوم استطاع
الحجامه المتمرنين
لكل ما هو موجود في المعسكر الخاص
التمرد في
ودي
اصاله وقوه ومتانت جنب القوات المسلحه
ودي اصاله
ومتانت بقوه
والناس بيقولوا من يوم عملوا القوات
المسلحه
حق الشعب والجيش حق المواطن لكن القوات
المسلحه ولدنا انها هي لا تتهاون ابدا في
حفظ امن واستقرار هذا الوطن العزيز اللي
هو
مواطنه وشعبه يتمتع بافضل الاخلاق باحسن
الصفات لذلك بيستحيك انه هو يكون عايش في
امر ويستحيل انه يكون عايش باستمرار ودي
القوات المسلحه اللي هي العامه الجايه
بتكمل
على هذا الكلام منذ انشاءه حتى
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لذلك
الامر لانه ده واجبنا ودي مهامنا يكفينا
لنا القانون
وما حيتخلى عنها ابدا لحد اخر يوم من
حياته
الله الله
وعلى وقع اطلاق النار دخلت الهدنه المعلنه
حيز التنفيذ لكن دون التزام طرفي النزاع
بها رغم مرور ساعتين عليها الا انها لم
تلقى اذان صغيره وقد دخلنا ايضا في المزيد
من الوقت بعدها طبعا الاشتباكات اشتدت
بمحيط مبنى القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
في العاصمه الخرطومه مع اتهام كل طرف
للاخر بخرق هذه الهدنه اما الامم المتحده
فاعلنتا فشل الهدنه فيما يعمل السودانيون
ويتمنون دقائق قليله من الهدنه لاستغلالها
للوصول الى مياه الشرب او الحصول على
المواد الغذائيه
[موسيقى]
الطاوله التي جلس سائل جهه واحده منها
للسنوات انقلبت والوساطه باتت مطلوبه لوعد
المواجهه المسلحه بينهما في مهد العاصمه
بعد اربعه ايام على انزلاق رجلي الحكم
العسكري في السودان الى مستنقع القتال
سيناريوهاتون ثلاثه محتمله رسمت لمستقبل
المواجهه بين قائد القوات المسلحه ونائبه
السيناريو الاول ذهب الى حرب الشوارع
طويله تنحصر في العاصمه مع محاوله كل طرف
فيها حسم المعركه لمصلحته لكنه ينتهي
بانتشار قوات الجيش السوداني في كافه
المناطق والاحياء فاعتماد الجيش
استراتيجيه استنزاف الموارد وتفوقه من
ناحيه المعدات العسكريه والطائرات قد يكون
نقطه الفصل على ارض المعركه حيث ستفقد
قوات الدعم السريع ذات التسليح الخفيف
والمتوسط مؤنها من وقود وذخيره وغذاء خلال
ثلاثه ايام من الاشتباك المتواصل اول
السيناريوهات رجح انسحاب احمدتي تكتيكيا
الى دارفور في حال حوصره من الجيش ليتظلل
بقواته المتمرده مجردا من اي او مشاركه
بالمشهد السياسي الا في حال التسويه اما
السيناريو الثاني فيتمثل بوقف لاطلاق
النار بعد وسطات عربيه وغربيه يليه بدء
عمليه التفاوض والمحاكمات العسكريه لينتهي
بدمج قوه الدعم السريع المتبقيه مع الجيش
فيما يشمل السيناريو الثالث وقف اطلاق
النار وعوده الجميع للتسويه وهنا الاحتمال
المطروح عدم وجود قوات الدعم السريع كطرف
رئيسيا في العمليه التفاوضيه والذهاب
لفتره انتقاليه جديده تهيئ للانتخابات
وينضم الينا من مدينه مراووي مراسل
العربيه نزار بقداوي اهلا بك معنا نزار
يعني كيف هي الاوضاع بعد دخول هذه الهدنه
هدنه 24 ساعه حيز التنفيذ
نعم تدخل هذه الهدنه هنا في الولايه
الشماليه في مدينه مروي بعد ان ذكر الجيش
السوداني بانه اجبر القوه التي كانت
تتمركز داخل مطار مروي وداخل القاعده
العسكريه الجويه
العملياتيه هنا في شمال السودان اجبرها
على مغادره هذه القاعده بعد ان استخدم
المدفعيه الثقيله في مواجهه قوات الدعم
السريع مضت اكثر من ساعتين على هذه الهدنه
والمعلومات تشير الى ان الطيران تم
استخدامه عصر ومتى هذا اليوم
لتشتيت ولضرب ولقصف القوات التي خرجت من
قاعده مروي واتجهت جنوبا ناحيه منطقه
الملتقى التي تبعد نحو 100 كم من هذه
النقطه هنا في مدينه مروي تم استخدام سلاح
الطيران العسكري تم تشتيك نحو السبعين الى
60 سياره تتبع لقوات الدعم السريع ايضا
المصادر والمعلومات اشارت الى ان هنالك
مجموعه داخل حدود محليه مروي ما زالت
تتمركز في بعض المناطق وربما هذه
التمركزات
اثارت مخاوف كثير من المواطنين الذين
تخوفوا من ان يدخلوا في مواجهات مباشره
وطلبوا بالحمايه من وجود هذه القوات
تبقى معنا نزار نشير الى الاخبار العاجله
الوارده عن وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان يقول من المهم وقف التصعيد
في السودان والعوده للاتفاق الايطاليه اذن
وزير الخارجيه السعودي يقول من المهم وقف
التصعيد في السودان والعوده للاتفاق
الايطالي نزار كنا نتحدث قبل قليل عن خبر
عاجل اخر متعلق بفرقه الهجان التابعه
للجيش السوداني تعلن سيطرتها على مواقع
الدعم السريع في مدينه الابيض اذا شرحنا
قليلا لنا وللمشاهدين تفاصيل اكثر ان كان
بخصوص يعني الهرميه المؤسساتيه العسكريه
في داخل الجيش هذه الفرق كم عددها كل فرقه
منها بماذا هي متخصصه واذا ما تحدثنا ايضا
جغرافيا عن الابيض ماذا تعني سيطره على
قواعد عسكريه للدعم السريع فيها
نعم طاهر السودان مقسم الجغرافيا وعسكريا
الى وحدات والى فرق عسكريه هذه الفرق لها
حدود مسؤوليه يعني على سبيل المثال هنالك
في ولايه شمال كردفان وفي عموم كردفان
فرقه الهجانه هي حدود المسؤوليه لهذه
الفرقه في منطقه شمال كردفان وفي حدود
كردفان تنشط عسكريا وتعمل على تامين
المرافق الاستراتيجيه
وتعمل على تامين الحدود ويمكن ان يتم
الاستعانه بهذه الوحدات في حاله الطوارئ
الان هذه الفرقه في حدود المسؤوليه تعمل
في وفي الابيض لكن الان في حاله طوارئ تم
استدعاء هذه الفرقه فرقه الهجانه ايضا
لدينا في وسط الشمال في مدينه عطبره
تتمركز قوات سلاح المدفعيه وسلاح المدفعيه
ايضا طاهر من الاهميه بمكان يتم الاستعانه
بهذا السلاح كما حدث هنا في منطقه مروي
شرق السودان ايضا هنالك ق الفرقه الشرقيه
في منطقه الفاو يتم الاستعانه ايضا بهذه
الفرقه في حالات الطوارئ كما يحدث الان في
هذه العمليات العسكريه هي تقسيمات تقوم
بها هيئه الاركان في الجيش السوداني تقسم
السودان جغرافيا وعسكريا كل منطقه لها
خصوصيه تقسم لها عدد افراد وقيادات واسلحه
بنوعيه مختلفه عليه فان هذه الوضعيه هي
وضعيه استدعت هذه القوات حتى تشكل دعما
وانسندا لما يحدث الان في الخرطوم وقوات
الهجانب الفعل وصلت من الابيض بعد ان
شاركت في عمليه عسكريه الى جانب سلاح الجو
الذي نشط خلال الساعات الماضيه في الابيض
وهنا في مروي لحسم كثير ما يقول بانها
تفلتات من قبل قوات الدعم السريعه نزار
يعني اليوم تحديدا وكذلك الايام الثلاثه
الماضيه يعني كان هناك تضارب بالانباء كل
طرف يعلن انه هو من يسيطر على مطار مروي
الان ما هو الوضع وكيف هي السيطره لصالح
مين من
يبدو ان نزار لا يسمعني الان يرك تايمز عن
مصادر تتحدث عن اصابه مدير مكتبه الاتحاد
الاوروبي للمساعدات بالسودان بالرصاص وكان
طاهر الجيش السوداني وصف الموقف العام
بانه مستقر عدا عن مناوشات في محيط
القياده العامه والمطار هناك تتركز
المناوشات والاشتباكات بين الطرفين بين
الجيش السوداني وايضا قوات الدعم السريع
طبعا كان هناك هدنه انسانيه دخلت حيد
التنفيذ في السودان بدايه من الساعه
السادسه مساء بالتوقيت المحلي هي لمده 24
ساعه ولكنها خلقت
في الولايات يمكن تم تسيطر عليها تماما
نحن نسيطر الان على القياده العامه
بالكامل مسيطره على مطار الخرطوم الرئاسي
اذا هذا تمرد واضح
ومقالون العسكري ان هذا تمر بالنسبه
للمبادرات بكل مبادره لكن الان الماركه
مع قوات الدعم السريع اثناء نفط ما بينما
يقوم به محمد حمدان وشقيقي
ضبابيه المشهد في السودان التي يسهم فيها
بشكل كبير دخان القذائف تنبع من سيل
الاخبار المضلله والكاذبه انتصارات اعلن
عنها الطرفان وصفت بالهشه حينا وبالكاذبه
احيانا دون معرفه الجانب المحق لكن
المعلوم ان المعارك تتركز في هذه المناطق
اي العاصمه الخرطوم اندرمان
ومراوين الخرطوم مهد المواجهه المسلحه ان
صح التعبير شهدت اشتعال الشراره الاولى
ففيها تتمركز المواقع الاستراتيجيه
والحيويه التي يتنازع الجيش وقوات دعم
السريع سيطر عليها
الاشتباكات احتدمت على تخوم القصر
الجمهوري ومقر القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه وقياده قوات الدعم السريعه اضافه
الى مطارات عسكريه ومدنيه لكن التركيز كان
على محيط القياده العامه للمقر اهميه
مركزيه لوقوعه وسط العاصمه فهو يتكون من
خمسه ابنيه ويضم وزاره الدفاع وقيادات
القوات البريه والبحريه والجويه
والاستخبارات العسكريه ما يعني ان الالمام
بكافه الجوانب العسكريه والامنيه في
السودان في جنوب الخرطوم وتحديدا قاعده
النجوم الجويه اظهرت فيديوهات احراق قوات
الدعم السريع لعدد من مروحيات الجيش
السوداني
الى مطار الخرطوم الان الذي يشكل محور
تصادم اعلامي من الجهتين واخر الروايات
تتحدث عن سيطره قوات حماتي قوات الدعم
السريع عليه مع استمرار الاشتباكات من وسط
السودان الى شماله ومطار اخر يشهد احتداما
للمعارك وهو مطار مروي الجيش اعلن قبل
ساعات سيطرته على غالبيته مع انسحاب اعداد
كبيره من قوات حمايه
ياتي ذلك في وقت تتواصل فيه عمليات الكر
والفر في مدينه اندرمان شبكات عنيفه مع
تحليق مستمر للطيران الحربي في سمائها
[موسيقى]
لا مويه لا كهرباء يعني
اربع يوم ما نايمين
على مدى السنوات الماضيه افسدته رصاصه
خرجت منذ اربعه ايام من قلب العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم ولتتحول بعدها البلاد
راويه الى ساحه حرب يديرها من كان يعد يعد
بحمايتها وحليف امس باتا
جبهه حرب جديده فتحت افواه السلاح في
السودان طرفها الحرب عسكريان كلاهما تمرس
في ميادين القتال بدرفورد اما وصفه الصداع
فمكوناتها تقتصر على وجود قوتين مسلحتين
داخل الدوله الواحده
مصير البلاد حاليا بات على راحتي من كان
من المفترض حمايته والقادم لا ينذر الا
بصيف حار سيثقل كاهل السودانيين مجددا بعد
ان عاشوا حروبا وانقلابات عده جلبت
الويلات لهم تاريخيا المره الاخيره التي
تقاتل فيها قائد عسكري ونائبه شرقي
افريقيا كان في جنوب السودان وقتل حينها
حوالي 400 الف شخص اما صراع اليوم فيزعزع
استقرار جارتها الشماليه وما يدور حاليا
فيه قد ينتهي فقط بفوز احدهم في المعركه
مع عدم استبعاد حرب اهليه طويله الامد قد
تجر جيرانها وفق صحيفه
على مدى السنوات الماضيه تشارك البرهان
واحمدت معارك عده معا يد واحده وقوه
مشتركه ففي عام 2021 اكد احمدتي لصحيفه
فاينشل تايمز ان قوات الدعم السريع تدعم
القوات المسلحه السودانيه فيما اخبر
البرهان الصحيفه الغربيه انه بمجرد اكتمال
الانتقال الى الديمقراطيه سيعود القاده
الى التكنات وسيتم اجراء تصويت في عام
وعود تبخرت مع اطلاق رصاصه الاولى منذ
اربعه ايام من العاصمه الخرطوم ليدخل
السودان ازمه خطيره ربما يمكن ان تحسم
صلحا او تتوسع وتاكل ما تبقى من البلاد
اياد حمود العربيه
وينضم الينا من الخرطوم مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك معنا سالم الان ما
الذي يحصل تحديدا في هذه الساعات من
الهدنه المفترضه المخروقه
نعم اهلا بكم بكل الساده المشاهدين بدايه
الاحداث تتسارع حقيقه بعد اعلان هذه
الهدنه كان ينتظر السودانيون ان تكون هذه
الهدنه بدايه حقيقيه لوضع حد
لهذا الاحترام ومن ثم النظر في بعض
القضايا الشائكه المتعلقه بقضاياهم
الانسانيه تحدث عن الساكنين في ولايه
الخرطوم وفي ولايات مختلفه كذلك من
السودان لكن مع بدايه هذه الهدنه
تم اطلاق اعير ناريه وكذلك مضادات
للطائرات وطائرات ايضا تحلق في سماء
الخرطوم واشتباكات كذلك في محيط القياده
العامه للجيش هنا في كارفور كذلك وفي
مناطق اخرى في الجريف شرق لقي ثلاثه اشخاص
حتفهم بوقوع مقذوف ناري عليهم وهم اخوه
ثلاثه وايضا لقي شخص اخر حتى هنا في كوبر
رجل كبير في السم كان يريد الذهاب الى
المسجد واص خلق ناري كذلك هذه الاحداث
كلها تاتي من بعد بدايه الهدنه التي تحدث
عنها الطرفان يضاف الى ذلك مقذوفنا لاخر
وقع هنا في منطقه بحري في منطقه الصافيه
واحترق البيت باكمله لكن لا توجد ضحايا
ولله الحمد فهذه ابرز الاحداث التي حدثت
من بعد اعلان هذه الهدنه حتى الان يضاف
الى ذلك ان ولايه الخرطوم كانت قد اعلنت
انها ستسعى الى حل مشكله المياه التي
يعاني منها سكان ولايه الخرطوم بمدنها
الثلاث وتحتاج الى تدخل سريع لان
الساكنين هنا او القاطنين في ولايات في في
المدن الثلاث في ولايه الخرطوم يعانون من
شحاد في المياه واضح من حركه المواطنين
حتى حينما يخرجون يحملون معهم الاواني
لجلب المياه من اي مكان وكان البعض منهم
يذهب الى النيل لجلب المياه من هناك لان
المدينه تكاد تكون خاليه من المياه ايضا
حتى في محلات البقالات والسوبر ما لا توجد
مياه للاسف هذا الامر ايضا يجعلنا نتحدث
عن الشح الذي بدا واضحا في الايام القليله
الماضيه وحتى الان بدا اوضح وهو الشح في
الغذاء في بعض السلع هناك ندره وهناك سلع
موجوده في البقالات الى ذلك ان هذه
المقالات تعمل في اوقات محدده تعرف عليها
السكان هنا هي مثل هذه الاوقات اي بعد
الافطار بساعه او ساعتين وتعمل حتى الساعه
العاشره والحاديه عشره ومن ثم تغلق
ابوابها في الصباح الباكر وفي النهار يصعب
على اصحاب هذه المقالات ان يباشروا
اعمالهم بقيه المحل التجاريه مغلقه يضاف
الى ذلك سوق بحري الذي احترق بالكامل نهار
اليوم
سالم يعني الجيش السوداني يتحدث عن انه
المناوشات تحصل من حين لاخر في محيط
القياده العامه وايضا المطار اود ان اسالك
عن مستشفيين موجودين بهذه المنطقه
الخرطومه مستشفى الشعب اللي هن بهذه
المنطقه المنطقه هل تم اخلاء المرضى
والكوادر الطبيه منهما لانه كان هناك
صعوبه بالوصول الى الموجودين في الداخل
مستشفى الخرطوم والشعب هو ذات الاسم هو
ذات المستشفى مستشفى الشعب او مستشفى
الخرطوم هو مستشفى الكبير هذا المستشفى
كانت قد اعلنت اطباء السودان المركزيه عن
خروجه عن الخدمه تماما والجيش السوداني
اليوم اعلن انه اجل الطلاب الذين كانوا
عالقين في جامعه الخرطوم اجلاهم عن طريق
بحري وحينما وصل الجيش السوداني الى منطقه
المنطقه التي تقع بالقرب من حي كوبر وما
كانت تسمى سابقا بموقف شندي في هذه
المنطقه حصل اشتباك واستطاع الجيش
السوداني اخراج هؤلاء واجلاء هؤلاء
المدنيين هذا ايضا يعني يرفق ببيانات
الجيش المتتاليه كان اخرها ان الجيش
السوداني تحدث انه اليوم في هذه العمليه
في اليوم بدا منفجر اليوم في العمليه
الثانيه من هذه الاشتباكات والتي
يراد منها التمشيط حول القياده العامه الى
وسط الخرطوم واجلاء الجيوب المتعلقه بقوات
نضيف هنا نقطه اخرى ان هناك مضادات
لطائرات تنطلق بين الفين والاخرى من منطقه
كافولي ببحرين كافولي مربع سته تنطلق
العديد من الاعره الناريه وكذلك مضادات
الطائرات هذه المنطقه
سالم بس اقاطعك لانه يعني
ذكرت موضوع المستشفيات قبل قليل لنتعرف
اكثر على هذا الواقع قبل ان نعود اليك
ارجو ان تتفضل بالبقاء معنا شكرا على كل
هذه المعلومات للان
لا يتسع المكان هنا مستشفيات تكاد تفيض
بالمرضى وان فاضت فلا مستلزمات فيها ربما
ولا حتى اكسجين
مستشفيات تحت القصف
بالتوقيت الحرج لم يتمكن مرضى الكلى من
اتمام جلسه غسل طارئه لكن ما ترى ايضا لم
يكن في الحسبان
ملاذ غير امن بعد قصف العديد من
المستشفيات وتوقف بعضها عن الخدمه هذا
مستشفى ابن سينا لا شيء غير النار تعرض
للدمار بعد سقوط قدائف عشوائيه عليه
بعيد الشير وهذا مشفى اخر سمي باسم الشعب
ولم يسلم من قدائف العسكر تدمر بالكامل
يعتبر من اكبر مستشفيات الخرطوم واكثرها
حيويه
ثم مراكز طبيه عده لكنها تعاني من نقص
المستلزمات والكوادر ايضا امر اثار قلقا
دوريا فضلا عن قلق السودانيين راح نشهد
اكيد انقطاع مش بس بمواد طبيه ولكن عدم
تسيير المرافق العامه راح يكون للاسف
الشيء اللي راح نواجهه
قريبا وهذا الشيء منه ابدا ايجابي بالعكس
لازم نتدخل بسرعه لما تتفاقم الاوضاع اكثر
واكثر دعوات حقوقيه لوقف اطلاق النار
نتابع هذه الصور مباشره
للرشاقات التي نراها مباشره في هذا الليل
الذي يخرق فيه كل ما اتفق عليه من هدنه
لاربع وعشرين ساعه كان من المفترض ان تبدا
عصر اليوم ولكنها ما لبثت وان خلقت من قبل
الطرفين وكما هو واضح اسفل الشاشه فان
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع كلا
الطرفين يتبادلان الاتهامات بشان خرق هذه
الهدنه
منذ ساعتها الاولى وكانت ايضا
العديد من الجهات والاحزاب السودانيه يا
طاهر دعت الى الالتزام بهذه الهدنه ولكن
ليس هنالك يعني وهذا الموضوع سنطرحه لاحقا
على ضيوفنا يعني ليس هنالك من اليه من
مراقبه او حتى عقبات على اي طرف يمكن ان
يخرق هذه
الهدنه طبعا نشاهد الصور المباشره اذا من
العاصمه الخرطوم التي اشتد
النزاع والاشتباكات فيها منذ اربعه ايام
اربعه ايام وقتله من المدنيين وايضا من
الجيش من الطرفين صحيح وليس هناك احد
يعتبر محميا يعني بالامس تحدثنا عن وزير
المعادن وما حصل لعائلته عن مقتل اثنين من
افراد عائلته وثلاثه اثنان منهم من
حراساته عن ايضا اصابه مدير مكتب الاتحاد
الاوروبي للمساعدات السودان بالرصاص وفقا
لنيويورك تايمز وهو نقلناه في هذه الساعه
اضافه الى المزيد من المواقع التي يسيطر
عليها الجيش ولكن احيانا يحصل كارو وفر
فيعني تنتصر قوات الدعم سريع ومن ثم ينتصر
الجيش مجددا وهكذا كروه فار في اهم
المواقع الحساسه في السودان طبعا
سالم انت معنا نستمع الى هذه الرشقات في
هذه الصور
المباشره
ماذا يمكن التعليق عليها
نعم التعليق عليها بان الامن استمعنا الى
اصوات مضادات للطائرات ليست ببعيده من هذا
المكان بمكان تواجدي وكنت اتحدث عن منطقه
كافوري المربع سته حيث معسكر للقوات الدعم
السريع كان هذا المعسكر من قبل هو تابع
لهيئه العمليات في جهاز المخابرات العامه
الى ان قررت الحكومه انذاك حل هذه الهيئه
وبعد ذلك اصبح هذا المعسكر تابعا لقوات
الدعم السريع قوات الدعم السريع الموجوده
هناك بحسب المصادر التي لدينا مجموعه من
القوات لا يعرف عددها ولكنها مجموعه مقدره
من هذه القوات موجوده في داخل هذا المعسكر
الطائرات السودانيه طائرات
الدفاع الجوي السوداني تاتي للاستطلاع
للنظر الى هذه القوات وعددها وتواجدها في
ذلك المكان بمجرد اقتراب هذه الطائرات
تعمل مضادات الطائرات مباشره من هذا
المعسكر لهذه الطائرات ما يجعل سكان منطقه
كافوري وكذلك كوبر وليستها ببعيدتين من
هذه المنطقه وكذلك منطقه العزبه ايضا في
هذه في كلها في هذه في هذا الحيز الجغرافي
من منطقه كافوري مربع سته تجعلها في مرمى
سالم الى لو سمحت نستمع قليلا الى اطلاق
النار واصوات الرصاص في قلب العاصمه واضح
انه المعركه تشتد يعني وطيصا
ولا تخف رغم الاعلان عن الهدنه في هذه
الساعات لا ندري اذا كان احد سيتمكن من
الوسطاء من الدول من الاقليم من المجتمع
الدولي
الى ان يعيد الهدنه الى نصابها ام لا
وقرقعه السلاح واضحه جدا في هذه الصور
الليليه خاصه بيظل تبادل على الاتهامات
بين الطرفين بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع بشان من خرق هذه الهدنه هذه الهدنه
مثل ما ذكرنا اذا نستمع الى هذه الاص وات
وايضا مضادات سالم يعني اود ان اسالك عن
راي وموقف الاحزاب السودانيه من هذا هذه
الهدنه التي الهشه
نعم الموقف المواقف السياسيه تجاه اختراق
هذه الهدنه ما زالت يعني لم تظهر بشكل جيد
لكن قبل هذه الهدنه كانت قد رحبت هذه
الاحزاب والاساسيه ترحيبا كبيرا بهذه
الهدنه ورات انها بدايه الانفراج لهذه
الازمه ولو قليله بالنظر الى القضايا
الانسانيه وانها بعد ذلك ستنساب مساله
الدعم الذي يحتاجه المواطلون الان كذلك
ستكون هناك ممرات امنه للوصول كل المعينات
اللوجستيه للمستشفيات خاصه ونحن قد تابعنا
في التقرير السرد لهذه المستشفيات
والاضرار التي لحقت بها العديد من
المستشفيات حقيقه كانت خارج الخدمه بسبب
هذه الاوضاع وشرح كذلك المعدل اللوجستيه
وشح في المياه كذلك والكهرباء كلها قضايا
انا ساضطر ان اغادر هذا المكان للسلامه
شكرا
في توخى سلامه والحذر دائما هذه اولويه
شكرا جزي لا لك ولكن تبقون معنا شبكه
مراسلينا من
عموم السودان لكي ننقل الصوره اول باول
لهذه الاحداث نستمع قليلا الى الصوت
الطبيعي من المصدر لاستمرار عمليات القصف
المتبادل في السودان في الخرطوم بين
الطرفي القتال نستمع
[موسيقى]
اصدرت مجموعه من قاده القوى السياسيه
السودانيه والحركات المسلحه بيانا دعت فيه
طرفي الصراع في السودان لوقف الاشتباكات
فورا الاجتماع طلب قوات الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع الالتزام بالهدنه وتغليب الحوار
والحل السلمي للازمه كما اعرب قاده القوى
السياسيه عن تقديرهم لمبادرات وقف اطلاق
النار لاغراض انسانيه كما طلب الاجتماع
الطرفين بالوفاء بالتزاماتهما اجابه
للحاجات الانسانيه الملحه للشعب السوداني
بيان القوه السياسيه حظ جميع المكونات
السياسيه والمدنيه والشعبيه للنائيه عن
الخطابات التي تؤجج الحرب والعمل المشترك
لحل مشاكل السودان وعدم توسيع رقعه الصراع
ومن الخرطوم ينضم الينا نور الدين بابا
بكر الناطق الرسمي باسم حزب المؤتمر
السوداني والقيادي في قوى الحريه والتغيير
اهلا بك سيد نور الدين يعني هل تستطيعون
التواصل مع المسؤولين عن الجيش مع البرهان
وحماد تيلي تهدئه الاوضاع ولترسيخ هذه
الهدنه التي خلقت منذ الساعات الاولى
لسيريان سريانها
التواصل مع الطرفين العسكريين لم يتوقف
منذ اطلاق الرصاص الاولى قبل ثلاثه ايام
هناك جهود تبذل حتى هذه الاطراف لوقف
اطلاق
الراء لله للمفاوضات صحيحه هذه
الجهود لم تكلل
النجاح
للتغيير المضاد من الاطراف المختلفه وايضا
هناك حاله من الاستغفار
بين الطرفين عن طريق انه يعني اسفلت تلفون
على اتجاه متعازي الاطراف هناك ايضا
وداخليه على راسها النظام السادس تعمل على
تاجيج هذا الصراع وتريد ان تمضي في هذه
الحرب التي انا اعتقد انه لا ينفصل فيها
احد الخادر فيها
السوداني والقادر فيها المواطن عظيم جدا
بس اشرت الى عده نقاط مهمه نتوقف فيها معك
لو سمحت انت قلت انه التواصل مستمر فيما
كان قيادات سياسيه اخرى تقول نحاول
التواصل مع الطرفين ولا نتمكن من ذلك من
الذي استطاع ان يتواصل حقيقه وما الذي
سمعه من الطرفين ما مطال ابرز مطالب
الطرفين لماذا لم تنجح هذه الهدنه حتى
الان
ظلت في تواصل تام على اطراف المتصارعه نحن
كمان ذكرت هناك عدم ثقه بين الاطراف فكان
الامر يمضي في
السودان باستمرار كبير هناك خلافات طبيعيه
فيما يتعلق بالافصاح الامني
وكيفيه اداره هذه العمليه ولكن سرعان ما
تسجلت هذه الاحداث باطلاق الرصافه الاولى
نحن هناك فرص ثالث قام باطلاق هذه
الرصاصها الطرف يدعى دوما كان يعني زرع
الفتنه بين المديين والعسكريين طارتا وبين
العسكريين والعسكريين
قوه من النظام السابق عن دوله عميقه
تؤثر على من على اي من الطرفين
اقامه بحملها لتاجيل الصراع بين بين
الطرفين وهذه الحمله ان شاهدها كل
السودانيين في الميديا وفي المنابر التي
ظل يقومون بها فيما بما فيها افطاراتهم
الاجتماعيه التي كانت تحرك للحرب بين بين
الطرفين انه نجحوا الى حد كبير في اطلاق
الرصاص الفوله ويجعلها حرب ولكن اعتقد انه
مازال هناك فرصه لتحكيم صوت العقل
السلاح وتفويت الغرفه يعني تتحدث عن
اتصالات لماذا لا نشهد مبادرات حقيقيه
لماذا لا يتم هناك يعني اقتراحات بلجنه
ربما مشتركه من الطرفين من مراقبه ربما
دوليه لهذه الهدى من
لمراقبه تنفيذها
مشكله الهدنه السابقه التي بين من ومن يتم
مناقشته
بين القوه السياسيه
والاطراف المتصارعه وايضا هناك المجتمع
الدولي
ه الهدنه
السابقه هذه التفاصيل ما هي
المساحه الهدنه وما هي يعني شروط هذه
الهدنه هل فيها تعمل وترتيب للقوات مره
اخرى هل هناك يعني
مسارات للجيوش هل هناك تحركات من منطقه
الى اخرى هل هناك زياده للتسليح هذه
النقاط اثرت على عدم التزام الطرفين لانه
هناك كما ذكرت عامل عدم الثقه بين هذه
الاطراف المتصارعه من الطرفين يظن انه في
هانز الهدنه يعني سيتغذى الطرف واحد من
الاطراف على الاخر بالتالي نعتقد انه الان
يجري بحث هذه التفاصيل حتى يتسنى القيام
بهدنه معروفه المسارات ومعروفه الشروط
وبلجنه يعني تراقب هذه نفسها يعني يمكن
عبر المجتمع الدولي ان تفرض اي عقوبات على
الطرف الذي يعني يقوم بكسر هذه الغنه حتى
يتسنى
للسودانيين العالقين في المنازل العالقين
في المستشفيات
العالقين في
يعني المتضررين بسبب الاوضاع الاقتصاديه
السيئه بسبب قيام الماء والكهرباء ان
يتحركوا ويثيروا وامورهم الحياتيه اليوميه
تجنبا لكارثه اقتصاديه وكارثه صحيه يمكن
ان تح
للاسف للاسف هذه نقاط مهمه جدا يجب ان
نبقي العين عليها دائما ولكن استغلالا
للوقت معك قلت قبل قليل انه النظام السابق
قوه منه استغلت الوضع واججزت الخلافات بين
الطرفين البعض قد يسالك ليس هذا يعني
استخداما لموضوع القوى او قوى النظام
السابق كشماعه تعلق عليها
كل عناوين الفشل التي تتحملونها كاسياسيين
مع الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في انقاذ
المرحله الانتقاليه هذا اولا ومن ثم اذا
كانت قوه النظام السابق التي كانت محسوبه
على الاخوان في بعضها متورطه في تاجيج
الخلاف من الذي تلومونه في ذلك هذا اتهام
للجيش او للبرهان او لكم
الحل السياسي هي تحركات كانت يعني هذه
معلومه لكل السودانيين هم سعوا كمان
سابقا لدعم انقلاب 25 اكتوبر هم سعوا لضرب
القوه المدنيه وبالقوه العسكريه وتصوير ان
الصراع ما بين المدينين والعسكريين يجب ان
يتصل به الس
انه الخلاف ليسوا ما بين المدنيين
والعسكريين ولكن ما بين
الاخرين موحدين في حل السياسي الذي كان
يؤمل بمدير عوده المسار المدني الديمقراطي
مره اخرى
مخطط
النظام السابق في النظام السابق للخطه
والتي
بموجبها الان يتم البلاد لحرب الشامله
يمكن ان تنتقل الى الولايات ويمكن ان تصلي
حرب اهليه ظنا منه انه المنفصل بهذه الحرب
يمكن ان يعود هو من خلاله او من خلال
الفوهه البندقيه مره اخرى وهكذا راحت على
على القوى الحريه والتغيير وعلى كل
الديمقراطيين والمطالبين بالتغيير
والانتقال الديمقراطي اليس كذلك
الان حمله توجه وتريد ان تحمل القوى
السياسيه يعني
ذنب الحرب وهي تعي تماما ان القوه
السياسيه تجنب هذا الخيار وتقدم التنازلات
تلو الاخرى وظلت تعمل يعني على اخماد سبيل
الازمه واخبار الصراعات وتوج يعني تقريبا
شعب النظر بين المكونات العسكريه حتى تبني
في السودان هذا الخيار هناك حمله الان
تريد القوه السياسيه حتى يتم المسائل
المدني الديمقراطي الى دوره لكم الان
حقيقه اليس كذلك هل هناك هل لكم دور الان
يعني البعض يقول انه راحت عليكم سنوات
الان لا دوره لكم الان الموضوع عسكري
عسكري محض ولا لن تتمكنوا من التدخل في
ذلك او التاثير
غير صحيح انه الان يعني متدخل بشكل رئيسي
في احتواء هذه الاسماء ووقفي اطلاق النار
ومحت انه لا منتصر في هذه الحرب ما زالت
هناك قوه مدنيه وما زالت اراده شعبيه لم
تقبل باي خيار يعيد السوداني الى مربع
الحكم الشمولي الديكتاتوري مره اخرى هناك
قوه مدنيه قويه في السودان تدعى لتحقيق
مطالب ثوره ثوره الجديده واستكمالا نحن
نعلم الان ونقدر انه يعني علو صوت الفكره
شكرا جزيلا لك السيد نور الدين بابا بكر
الناطق الرسمي باسمي حزب المؤتمر السوداني
والقيادي في قوى الحريه والتغيير
[موسيقى]
لا حول ولا
قوه
الله اكبر الله اكبر منصور باذن الله
منصورين ان شاء الله مصورين الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
ان شاء الله ما في اي خان في البلد دي
[موسيقى]
ولا جنب المطار
كويس
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر لسه لسه
ان شاء الله ما في
[موسيقى]
بعد اربعه ايام على القتال هدنه لمده 24
ساعه وافق عليها طرف الصراع الهدنه تتضمن
وقفا لاطلاق النار وفتح ممرات امنه الى
جانب عدم توقيف المواطنين او اعتقالهم
الهدنه تشمل بحسب مصادر العربيه المساعده
في حركه المحتجزين داخل بعض المؤسسات
الحكوميه نحن الجيش السوداني اعرب للعربيه
عن التزامه بالهدنه كما اكد عضو مجلس
السياده شمس الدين كباشي في تصريحات
للعربيه انه تمت الموافقه على الهدنه شرط
ضمان التزام الدعم السريع
المستشار السياسي للدعم السريع بدوره اكد
للعربيه توجيه جميع القوات التابعه لهم
بالالتزام بالهدنه
الجيش السوداني سبقت دعم السريع بالالتزام
بالهدنه بعد اتصال هاتفي مع وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي
اذا قبل ان نذهب لنتحدث عن تفاصيل اكثر
حول هذه الازمه مع الدكتور الرشيد نشاهد
هذه الصور وهذا الفيديو الذي وصلنا عن
اعتقال الجيش السوداني لقائد قوه الدعم
السريع في مروي
[ضحك]
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ونذكر مشاهدينا الكرام بان وزير الخارجيه
السعودي قد تلقى اتصالا من نظيره الامريكي
تركز على الوضع في السودان
والامير فيصل بن فرحان والوزير انتونيكن
اكد على اهميه وقف التصعيد العسكري في
السودان اخر التحركات الدبلوماسيه حول ما
يحدث في السودان من تطورات
الصور المباشره اذا العاصمه الخرطوم بعد
سريان هدنه وقف اطلاق النار وينضم الينا
الدكتور الرشيد ابراهيم رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه
لنتحدث عن هذه
الازمه بمركز طبعا العلاقات الدوليه
والدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم دكتور الرشيد هذه
الهدنه التي يعني خرقت بسرعه منذ الساعات
الاولى لسريانها ما مالات هذا النزاع
برايك وهل يمكن ان يبنى اصلا على يعني
هدنه هشه
نعم يعني لم يكن هنالك تفاؤل كبير لدى
المراقبين والمتابعين
للاحداث في الخرطوم ان تنجح هذه
المهله او الهدنه ولكن هذا لا يمنع ان
يكون هنالك مساء اخرى وتفاهمات اخرى ولكن
الراجح ان
انهيار الهدنه هو يعطي مؤشرا على ان
القادم هو تصعيد
واذا يعتمدنا يعني على التغرير الميداني
الذي اصدره
مكتب الناطق الرسمي باسم القوات المسلحه
ذكر بعض الاحداث منها استعاده قاعده مروي
والاحداث في الهجان التي اوردها التقرير
وتحدثنا عنها وذكر ان هنالك تورط
للدول الاقليميه ومجموعات داخليه في هذه
المؤامره التي يعني هي
حادثه التمرد على الدوله وحديث البرهان
ان هنالك انقلابا من قبل قوات الدعم
السريعه افتكر انه هذه المعلومه ايضا ربما
تشكل ماده
وسيترتب عليها
يعني ما بعدها لان القوات المسلحه في
البيان ذكرت ستفصح عن هذه التفاصيل
يعني في وقت لاحق هذا ايضا ربما يعطينا
مؤشرات
للتحليل في اذا اردنا الدكتور وانت تتحدث
نستمع اعذرني على المقاطعه النستمع الى
هذه الرشاقات المباشره من العاصمه الخرطوم
الاصوات القصف والمدافع والرشاشات
والرشاشات تزداد شيئا فشيئا مع يعني هذه
الساعات من الليل ليوم كان من المفترض ان
يشهد ابنه ولكن هدنه انهارت منذ ساعاتها
الاولى بدون اي بوادر حتى الان على
امكانيه انقاذها في ساعاتها المتبقيه وهنا
نسال دكتور رشيد ما تفسيرك لهذا الانهيار
بما ان الطرفين من المفترض انهما وافقا
على هدنه لاربع وعشرين ساعه لماذا فشلت
بهذه السرعه لا يبدو ان ايا من الطرفين
كان لديه النيه الحقيقيه لكي يلتزم بها ام
ان هناك طابورا خامسا قد يكون مستفيدا من
هذا الوضع
نعم الطرفين يحمل كل منهما الاخر ولكن
السبب الجوهري بالنسبه هو ما ذكره في
حاطته لمجلس الامن من ان قوات الدعم
السريع فقط السيطره على وحداتها بفعل ضرب
مراكز السيطره وبالتالي ليس لديها الغتره
على ارسال هذه التعليمات ان كان حديث فوق
كلر لمجلس الامن صحيحا فيبقى انه لا
امكانيه للالتزام بالهدنه ان كان ليس
هنالك سيطره والقوات الدعم السريعه تعمل
كجزر معدوله ومجموعات متفرغه ايضا
الانهيار هذا ايضا يعطي مؤشرا ان هنالك
رؤيه
للقوات المسلحه استنادا على التقرير
الميداني الذي صدر قبل قليل بانها دخلت
المرحله الثانيه من تنفيذ
العمليه العسكريه التي تعتبر انها منضبطه
في توسيع قاعده التامين بالنسبه للمراكز
الرئيسيه ودائره التامين الاولى في
الخرطوم بما يشمل القصر الجمهوري والقياده
العامه وبالتالي
يعني التوجهاتها في انها تحسن ربما
الموقف الامني وان وبالنسبه لها من واقع
خطتها التي هي تلتزم بها حتى ولو انه لم
يحدث اختراق يعني قطعا ستمضي القوات
المسلحه في تنفيذ هذه الخطه والتي اكدت في
بيانات سابقه بانها قريبه جدا من احداث
النصب وما هي الا ايام او ليله وضحاها
وسوف يتبين الخيط الاسود من الخيط الابيض
من الفجر ويمكن بعضها ان نتحاكم وان يكون
هنالك مساحه من بعد
بصوره وصوت نعم سيشاركنا بالحديث السيد
شريف محمد عثمان الامين السياسي لحزب
المؤتمر السوداني والمتحدث باسم الحريه
والتغيير ونحن نستمع لاصوات الرشقات
بسماء العاصمه الخرطوم التي لم تتوقف وهي
متقطعه سيد شريف يعني دعنا نتحدث عن ما
يمكن يعني ان يحدث بالساعات القادمه هذه
الهدنه سرعان منهاره والقوى السودانيه
السياسيه تحذر من خطر كبير على الدوله اذا
فشل وقف النار
[موسيقى]
الطائرات المرئيه والاشتباكات الدايت في
مناطق عديده في ولايه الخرطوم وايضا في
الولايات عده في كردفان في الشماليه وفي
جنوب
عدد كبير من الضحايا المدنيين في مناطق
متسحب عليهم جميعا كل ما اعلنا القوه
المدنيه اليوم ايضا
من اقوى الثوره والضرب بيان حست فيه
سودانيين على التماسك
على الحرب وتدعو جميعا الاطراف الحرب
العينه
اعتقد ان هذا الامر ايضا هو امر جيد تماسك
القوه المدنيه ومطالباتها الواضحه ايضا
اللقاء الثلاثيه اليوم والذي ضم اطراف من
عمليه السلام وهو الحريه والتغيير
ايضا هذه الخطوه
جيده الى حد ما
ومطالبات هذه القوه مجتمعه بان المطلب
الحالي هو مرتبط باضافه
الحرب ونبذ الخطابات الحاده على الكراهيه
والاسترطاب
معلش اذا سمحت لي يعني وسط كل ما نسمعه
وانت تحت الان وهو كل هذا القصف المستمر
وهذه الاصوات التي ترعب السودانيين في
الداخل اعنهم الله على هذه الايام العصيبه
التي يعيشونها كل كلام نظري يعني تنظير
سياسي لا طائله منه من الذي يستمع اليه من
القوى المتحاربه الان
المجتمع السوداني على التماسك وعلى
الكراهيه على الحرب ومطالبات
المسلحه ولقائد الدعم السريع يعني الى صوت
العقل وان يوقفوا هذه الحرب
بالاتفاق السياسي هذا الامر هذه هي
ما يتمكن القوه المدنيه من شانه في هذا
اللحظات بالاضافه للاتصال
بالمجتمع الدولي والاقليمي لضمان ان يتوحد
الموقف ضد الله ضد الحرب وان يمنع تدخل
ذلك سيد شريف من الذي يضمن ذلك يعني وهل
تعتقد ان الضغوطات الدوليه على طرفي
النزاع كافيه من دون ضمانات
نحن نتحدث عن الادوات
استخداما من قبل القوه المدنيه في النهايه
القوه المدني الادوات التي تمتلكها هي
ادوات للاتصال الاتصال
السياسيه ولجانه المفاوض وكل الفاعلين في
العمل المدني بان تتوحد هذه القوه ضد ضد
هذه الحرب ضد خطابات التي تحد على على
الحرب وايضا نمتلكه وايضا هو الاتصال بكل
بكل العالم وبكل اصدقائنا السودان لان
يدعموا هذه يدعموا هذه الجهود هذه الجهود
في النهايه تواصلت
ان تمارس الضغوط على الاطراف المتحاربه
تمام
على الاخضر واليابس ستورد السودان مولد
الحلاق نحن سنكتفي معك بهذا القدر للان
ولكن لا نعود اليك ان شاء الله في سياق
تغطياتنا استاذ شريف محمد عثمان الامين
السياسي لقوى الحريه والتغيير لحزب
المؤتمر السوداني والمتحدث باسم القوى
الحريه والتغيير شكر جزيلا لك شكرا ايضا
للدكتور رشيد ابراهيم رئيس قسم العلوم
السياسيه بمركز العلاقات الدوليه
والدبلوماسيه في الخرطوم ولبقيه ضيوفنا
ومراسلين راويه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات